foreign
[Music]
do you know that feeling when you're
doing exactly what you were put on the
earth to do the one where it's like
everything inside you is moving together
in harmony with the universe
me neither
but you know one can hope right
wave to Mommy because she'll hate me
even more than she already does if you
don't I seem to recall you saying that
becoming a lawyer would only crush your
soul yeah it is I'm running a business
right now that business is getting a
journalist and I'm not a paledonia
[Applause]
no no and no who's a journalist I have
resigned my position here
20 grams as you are
welcome president finaga so nice to meet
you
you must take a selfie you approved
there are so many wonderful things about
my country
thank you
oh
stay here
what the hell just happened you're one
man's security detail happened he's a
human I'm not the president of a country
in the middle of a coup this is the
scoop of a lifetime You're Gonna Be
Alive down the scoop for a lifetime
you never should have come let's go
can't just leave him
[Music]
I'm just doing my job
laughs
did you help
get up again now I got to win I get up
again
oh my God
oh Color Me impressed Mr Potato
tell me you got that run
[Music]